تداعيات ملف وثائق الفينتاجون المسربه
تتواصل يوما بعد يوم وجديدها تقرير جديد
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه وفقا
للتقرير مسرب الوثائق السريه هو شاب
امريكي قام بمشاركتها مع مجموعه من معارفه
واصدقائه على تطبيق ديسكورد الشعب يحمل
الاسم المستعار او او جي وقال لي زملائي
في المجموعه انه حصل على الوفائع خلال
عمله في قاعده عسكريه لم يحددها وتحدث احد
افراد المجموعه لواشنطن بوست قائله ان
الشاب نشر مئات الرسائل طوال اشهر منها
مقتطفات استخباريه سريه وبحسب الصحيفه قال
اوجي لرفاقه انه نسخ الكثير من تلك
الوثائق باليد لانها موجوده في اماكن
يحضر على اشخاص معينين دخولها وحمل
الهواتف او حتى الاجهزه الالكترونيه كما
كشف عدوان في المجموعه عن انهما يعرفان
الاسم الحقيقي لاوج اضافه للولايه التي
كان يعيش ويعمل فيها لكنهما لم يكشف
المعلومه من جانبها تمكنت صحيفه من الوصول
الى الشخص الذي من المحتمل ان يكون مسرب
الوثائق من خلال ملفه الشخصي الخاص
بالالعاب عبر الانترنت وايضا سجلات اخرى
بحسب المعلومات الاوليه فان جاك تكشيره
تتطابق مواصفاته وعمله مع تفاصيل موجوده
على هوامش بعض صور الوثائق السريه المسربه
الشاب طيار بالحرس الوطني يدير مجموعه تضم
نحو 30 شخصا اكدت والدته للصحيفه ان ابنها
كان يعمل في نوبات ليليه في قاعده كيب كود
في الولايه التي يعيش فيها وانه غير رقمه
رقم هاتفه في الايام القليله الماضيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات